-Our guest tonight hosts
the Emmy- and Peabody-winning
show "Last Week Tonight,"
which airs Sunday nights on HBO
and streams on HBO Max.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend, our good friend,
John Oliver.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you. Thank you.
-I wanted to make it clear.
-Yeah, that was good.
My stomach's --
Stop them. Stop them.
-You stop it!
-Stop it.
-This --
-You have the power.
-Let me explain
something to you.
-You have the power.
-What you're doing right now is
Kryptonite to this British man.
-That's right, he doesn't --
I do --
-He does not want your praise
or attention.
-I do not thrive on that.
I'm diminished by it.
Yeah, thank you
for the correction.
-Yeah.
-Good friend, not friend.
I will be listening so carefully
when you introduce someone
as "friend" in the future
and leave it there.
-Yeah. I'm just going to be
real dead.
I'm, "Please welcome
our friend."
-[ Laughs ]
-And that's it.
-That's right.
-Interestingly, the last
couple times you were here
have been big days
for the royal family news.
Last time you were here was
the funeral of the Queen.
And the time before that --
-Thank you for that.
-You're very welcome.
-Thank you, yeah.
-It was a couple days after
Prince Philip died.
-Thank you, thank you.
-You're very welcome.
-Wow. You're coming at me with
a lot there.
-We kind of have a vacuum of
royal family news right now.
-Well, we have a vacuum
as we not --
I mean, you tape hours
before broadcast.
-That's true.
-We don't know what's going
to happen between now
and this show goes out.
Maybe Charles has thrown himself
off the roof
of Buckingham Palace, saying,
"My family is built on blood."
It would be terrible.
I would respect it,
but it would be terrible.
-Okay.
-Also, before the royal deaths,
before natural selection
went 2 for 2.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-The time before that I was here
and COVID was breaking out.
-Yes, that's true.
-We do tend -- it's not like
there's going to be a run
on the banks, right?
-Yeah.
-Right, Seth?
-You're sort of a news reaper.
[ Laughter ]
-Or a crisis fluffer.
-Yeah.
You're a crisis fluffer. You
make us feel a little better.
-I'm sure the banks
are going to be fine.
That segment was great.
-Well, thank you very much.
I mean, if they weren't going
to be fine,
I think that segment fixed it.
-I think what we all need,
more than anything right now,
is for Jim Cramer to shut
the [bleep] up.
He's in this building, right?
-He might be in this building.
You can sometimes hear him based
on -- yeah.
-Someone in this building
needs to take
a tranquillizer dart
and just [blows]
get that right.
-Although he does feel like
one of those gorillas
that can actually --
-Fight through it.
-Throw it down.
-Throw it back at you.
-"Buy! Buy Chase Bank.
Everything's gonna be fine!"
Oh, no, Jim, not like this.
[ Laughter ]
-You were counterprogrammed
last night
with a pretty big event.
The Oscars were your competition
last night.
-Yeah, that's right.
-Yeah.
-I mean, you're stretching
the definition of the term
"competition" there.
[ Laughs ]
Oscars is one of the most
glamorous nights that humanity
produces each year.
We counterprogram that with
talking about the temporary
assistance for needy families
program for 22 minutes.
yeah, we were the opposite
of the Oscars.
-And you didn't have
a red carpet last night?
I can't remember.
-I mean, we did.
But it didn't get any
of the attention, yeah.
-I thought our colleague,
Jimmy Kimmel,
did a fantastic job last night.
-He did great.
Yeah, I watched him, and then --
Yeah, awesome.
He's great at it.
-Would you ever want to
host an event like that?
-No. And I don't -- It's not
even that I wouldn't want to.
I don't think it would be a net
benefit for anyone involved.
'Cause the great thing
about Kimmel, right,
is that he is obviously funny,
but also, he has, like --
you're confident that there
is this low-lying contempt
for the whole event.
-Yep.
-And you're confident that
it's there,
but he somehow doesn't manage
to poison the room.
-Yes.
-With that visible contempt.
And that is a kind of
magic trick I couldn't do.
I could not at any point say,
"It's going to be
a magical night."
I'd say, "It's not, though,
is it?"
These are some of the most
over-praised people on Earth,
and we're going to give them
shiny trophies
like they're dogs.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. I couldn't --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's not me. No one wants it.
-I couldn't ever imagine
you saying anything is gonna be
magical without you being ironic
or sarcastic.
-I couldn't do it.
I tried.
Sometimes even at benefit gigs.
-Yeah, we do charitable
events.
-Yeah, you're good at them.
-Oh, that's very kind.
-You have the Kimmel skill of
not ruining everyone's evening.
I really struggle with that.
The only one I can kind of do
functionally
is the "Sesame Street" Gala
because they're nice, right?
So they need a bad guy.
They need a bad cop,
and I'm willing to be
Elmo's bad cop.
So they can say, "Oh, we're all
here to have fun."
And I can say, "We're not,
actually, Elmo.
We're here to squeeze that table
of bankers at Goldman Sachs
for more money than
they're willing to spend.
Go away.
Don't be here when
the transaction happens, Elmo.
Mafia rules only here."
-Do you feel like you
have a good working relationship
with the Muppets now, based on
your time at those benefits?
-Yeah, actually. Not bad.
Like, I really love them.
The first time I met one, and I
still can't really think of it
as the puppeteer, I did
something with Cookie Monster.
And he was so funny.
And I had heard that one of the
old writers of "The Daily Show,"
Rich Blomquist,
had met Fozzy Bear once
when Kristen Schaal
was in the Muppet movie.
And he'd said he wanted to meet
Fozzy Bear.
And so he's talking to him
and he just instantly forgets
there's a guy underneath him
and starts saying to him,
"I think you're the reason
I got into comedy, Fozzy."
[ Laughter ]
-And you can feel the puppeteer,
he said he could feel him go,
"Oh, [bleep], this is one
of those conversations.
Okay. Oh.
You're welcome, waka waka waka."
But he said, he just had this
very sincere monologue
about, "I think you
fundamentally changed
the way my life has gone."
-I did a Weekend Update
feature once with Kermit.
And one of my favorite photos
at my time at "SNL,"
is -- it was during rehearsal,
and I'm just looking --
I'm giving a note to Kermit.
And it's just this picture of me
talking to him
like he's listening.
-Yeah.
-And I know the dude is right
there, and I'm like --
-It's incredible.
-Yeah.
-That is how amazing they are.
I was doing that whole thing
with Cookie Monster.
I never once did I look
that poor guy in the face.
[ Laughter ]
It's just straight like, "Oh,
I'm getting on well
with Cookie Monster.
It's a bit weird that this guy
is around all the time.
-Later you say to that guy,
"What's it like working
with Cookie Monster everyday?"
He's like, "It's me!"
-No, it's not you.
It's not you.
You seem angrier.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, we'll be right back
with more from John Oliver.